étranger
depuis que j'ai été mordu par cette araignée,
nous avons eu une semaine
où ma vie semblait normale,
c'est à ce moment-là que vous avez découvert
[Musique]
lorsque vous avez bâclé ce sort où vous
vouliez que tout le monde oublie que Peter
Parker Spider-Man
a commencé à recevoir des visiteurs
[  Applaudissements]
de tous les univers
bonjour Peter
tu n'es pas Peter Parker
Je suis désolé, quel était ton nom encore Dr
Otto Octavius
ouais
attends non sérieusement quel est ton vrai
nom
il y en a d'autres là-bas nous devons
les renvoyer
alors
abandonne tu sais tout ça  c'est un peu que
tu es en désordre, je connais moi-même quelques
mots magiques commençant par le mot s'il te plaît,
vole dans l'obscurité pour combattre les
fantômes, que veux-tu dire, ils meurent tous en
combattant Spider-Man, c'est leur destin
désolé gamin
ouais moi aussi ne le fais pas
Ecoute, il doit y avoir une autre victoire,
leur danger pour notre univers,
tu ne vas pas m'enlever ça
Peter,
tu te bats, [ __ ],
tout ce que tu veux pendant que le monde
essaie de te faire choisir,
c'est entièrement de ma faute, je ne peux pas sauver tout le monde.
Applaudissements] qu'est-ce qui se
passe, ils commencent à
s'en sortir et je ne peux pas les arrêter le
17 décembre exclusivement dans les
salles de cinéma en vente le 29 novembre
lundi araignée